this
study paints a fascinating picture of a
future
um where first for medical applications
but then also
in general psychedelics of various forms
could be used by the broader society
forgive the perhaps ridiculous question
but
if much of society including our
politicians
are taking psychedelics
and dissolving their ego and going
through this whole process
how how do you think the world may look
different
in 20 30 50 years ah
okay so um i i said that i think
licensed legalization happens in 2035
yes
all right so and i think by 2050
we will have enough people hopefully
spiritualized we're also talking about
um we hear so much in terms of
climate change about uh you know net
zero carbon
so our goal is net zero trauma
when do we have a world with net zero
trauma i mean right now
you know we have two sites in israel so
we help a few people but the recent war
with gaza
has traumatized millions of people on
both sides so
we are a long way away from net zero
trauma
but that's the hope and that's i think
possible i think humanity as a whole
is like lemmings heading over a cliff
with climate change and with the
nuclear proliferation and just the the
religious hatreds and the more the
retreat to authoritarianism and
fundamentalism
and tribalism so i i think that there's
a very good chance though that
psychedelics used wisely so it's not
just make psychedelics
legal and everybody takes them and you
know as you talked about ted kaczynski
you know
it's the context that people take it in
but i think that there's
um a reasonable chance that
enough people can sort of you could say
clean their filters to see
people as more similar to them than
different
not to label them as the enemy um stan
groff again had this beautiful phrase
about
um transparent to the transcendent
the death that's what yeah so for our
ego can can we be transparent
to the transcendent because can the
filter that we look through the world
at be cleaned to um you could say
cleansing the doors of perception you
know
can it be cleaned to the point where we
can see the humanity in everybody
and see that um
one way to say this is that can we get
to the point where religions are seen as
like languages
where we all have this need to
communicate there's
thousands of different languages you
know we don't say that this language is
fundamentally better than this language
this language is the only right language
everybody must speak english and
russian is bad or german is better you
know maybe we'll get to that point that
that religions are like that that their
different cultural backgrounds different
symbol systems
different saints and heroes and messiahs
and all this but that
you know yeah jesus is the son of god
but so are we so is everybody
you know or yes you know the jews are
the chosen people but so is everybody
so can we get there i think that we can
and i think that we need to to survive
the challenges that we're facing
and the hope is that by bringing
psychedelics as tools forward and trying
to bring
the context around them to be one of
responsibility rather than just profit
maximization
and just you know get as many people to
do them from all these for-profit
companies
you know can we and then also drug
policy reform and embed
knowledge in the society can we get to
honest drug education
you know dare the drug uh awareness
resistance
uh education you know is fundamentally
twisted uh
i mean but it's the program that's used
in a lot of schools now
so can we get honest drug education pure
drugs harm reduction
and knowledge about therapeutic uses and
um
on the one hand and and more of these
thousands of psychedelic clinics
i'm hopeful and that's our goal
you